this is Howard he's four months old he
lived in California with his family to
kiss his mom Domino is his dad and Boo
is his sister
they are pileated Gibbons this species
is found in Thailand Cambodia and Laos
in the wild they are threatened by
habitat destruction and the wild animal
trade they live mostly in trees and all
Gibbons have strong arms and legs the
long muscular arms help them move
through the branches with impressive
speed romantic by nature pileated Gibbon
couples are usually monogamous often
staying with their partners for life
given couples form strong bonds grooming
each other and hanging out in trees both
males and females are similar in size
and have a cooperative family dynamic
families do everything together and when
the children are grown they leave to
create their own families BB Gibbons
learn how to grasp their mothers hair
from early on and will nurse for the
first two years of their life Howard
hasn't started swinging on his own yet
but he'll be ready to start learning
soon this is the pileated given this is
a baldric re monkey
these monkeys are mostly known for their
bright red faces which are an indicator
of good health sick monkeys develop pale
faces
unlike most primates beaultiful caries
have very short tails and long coats the
Vicari is an arboreal primate which
means they live in the treetops mostly
because of far as flooding in the rainy
season during the dry season they return
to the ground to look for seed the
boardwalk re are native to the western
Amazon of Brazil and Peru and are
considered of vulnerable species female
carries can only give birth to a single
infant every two years so the population
can tour rapidly these primates are
threatened primarily by hunting and
destruction of their habitat mostly by
deforestation
this is a bold wa carry monkey
[Music]
this is Olivia a North American river
otter Olivia is only 8 months old but is
quite the playful otter pup river otters
are semi aquatic they live both on land
and in water and have adapted for both
environments they have thick protective
fur to help them stay warm while
swimming in cold water and short legs
and webbed feet to help them swim
quickly river otters can stay underwater
for as long as 8 minutes and use their
long whiskers to find prey in we often
cloudy water in which they swim in the
late-1980s
north american river otters are extinct
throughout many of their natural
habitats due to fur trapping and poor
water quality through reintroduction
programs and the fur trade management
their populations have risen and
stabilized this is the north american
river otter
this is Sawadee an African lion these
stunning big cats are Africa's apex
predator they once were most of Africa
and parts of Europe and Asia but today
they are only found in parts of
sub-saharan Africa
Zawadi is a male lion indicated by his
large main lines are considered the only
social member of the cat family and live
in large groups called prides females do
most of the hunting and work in teams
ambushing their prey their importance to
the ecosystem is paramount playing a key
role in the food chain
controlling herbivore populations but
while they are the alpha predators they
face threats of their own a combination
of trophy hunting and habitat loss has
cut their population in half over the
past two decades this is the African
lion this is Tommy a Tasmanian devil
he's got a tough exterior but his
species needs all the help they can get
the only thing that this guy has in
common with his cartoon namesake is his
temperament when threatened Tasmanian
Devils launch into fits of growling
lunging and otherworldly screams the
origin of the devil part of his name
they will once found all across
Australia but now only survive in the
island state of Tasmania while they'll
scavenge for just about anything alive
or dead they're best known as ferocious
predators to small birds mammals and
reptiles
but fan no match for deadly disease the
last wild Tasmanian devil population
have been plagued by a very specific
cancer to face causing them to starve
the disease has run rampant but thanks
to concerted effort this species is
getting back to fighting strength this
is it has Manian devil meet Morrison and
tingoora two adorable dingo no these
aren't pet dogs they're actually wild
animals dingoes are australia's wild
dogs considered a cultural icon but due
to interbreeding pure dingers have
become harder to spot hence both Molson
and tangora's similar appearance to
domestic dogs dingoes are thought to
have been introduced to Australia three
to four thousand years ago they are
Australia's largest terrestrial predator
fingers hunt everything from rodents and
birds to larger prey like kangaroos they
are a big part of Aboriginal Australian
culture yet are seen as pests by
livestock farmers due to perceived
attacks on animals hunting for their
skin and interbreeding has left their
population vulnerable this is the dingo
this is Charlotte a prehensile-tailed
porcupine with her short thick spines
she's adorably speckled but that cute
little outfit is actually an excellent
defense mechanism her spine fries up
when threatened to give a larger and
more threatening appearance Charlotte
will spend most of her life in the trees
deep in the forests of Central and South
America she feeds on bark leaves fruits
and roots her feet have long curved
claws making her an adept climber while
prehensile-tailed porcupines are
permitted of protecting themselves they
are less successful against humans as
they are hunted for food in parts of
their habitat that along with a
diminishing territory have left their
population in flux this is the
prehensile-tailed porcupines this is
pink a southern three-banded armadillo'
predators look elsewhere you'll have a
hard time cracking urban miss critter
like all armadillos they are covered by
Burnie plates that make up their shells
but the southern three-banded armadillo'
is the only armadillo species that can
roll themselves into a near perfect bowl
when threatened
these little guys are native to central
South America and preferred dry
vegetation there they feed up in fact
that they dig up with their sharp
powerful claws and gather with long
sticky straw like tongue but even body
armor can't protect this species from
numerous human-made threats on top of
the dwindling habitat they are hunted
heavily for food and the pet trade this
is the southern three-banded armadillo'
[Music]